chance angela merkel and germany's
regional leaders are expected to extend
germany's coronavirus lockdown as
infections remain stubbornly high
schools are currently closed and the
current restrictions were originally due
to expire
next week now parents are bracing for
yet more home-based learning
students in germany have not yet
returned to the classroom after the
christmas break
most schools will stay closed until
january 10th while others are offering
virtual lessons
germany's federal and state governments
now have to decide on the way forward as
calls grow for schools to stay closed
even longer or to only open partially
in berlin opinions on the matter vary
i have two children myself one in high
school and one in elementary school
i think schools should remain closed a
little longer even though it's difficult
for us
parents perhaps we can find a good
balance with some learning at home and
others allowed to be in school
i think that as long as the lockdown
stays in place and i expect it will be
extended
children should stay at home hope for a
return to normal lies with the vaccine
as of monday germany had administered
almost 266 thousand jabs
but the government is coming under
pressure its vaccination program has
been criticized for being slow and
chaotic
german health minister jens spann
defended his government's plan
is the issue is the vaccine delivery
biontech pfizer have always said they
could only produce 50 million doses
worldwide by the end of 2020
that explains this initial shortage the
second issue is that those german states
that are vaccinating are doing so mostly
in nursing homes
we have always said that this will take
a little longer because of course the
process there is more complicated
new cases and deaths have remained high
over the holiday period
now medical experts report germany's
critical care units are nearing capacity
let's bring in dw's julia saudelli with
the latest on this story hi julia
there are media reports that lockdown
measures could get even
tougher in germany so what is going to
be decided today
what we know is that there is consensus
for the current lockdown to be extended
at least till the end
of january and media reports are now
talking about
the chancellor angela merkel wanting to
put forward a proposal
to sharpen the measures and to introduce
a limitation to where people
can go outside their homes in the areas
that are most affected by the
coronavirus
this suggestion comes after having
spoken to health experts here
in the country we will see how that will
go down with the state premiers
another issue as we saw in the report is
schools they will have to decide what to
do
going forward whether to keep them
closed open partially or
what solution to go along with at the
same time the infection rates the death
toll is still very high in germany
where has the government's strategy
until now gone wrong
one point that is uh has been criticized
in germany has been
how late the harsher lockdown has come
into place
it only came into place in mid-december
after a month and a half of a lighter
lockdown
and even chancellor angela merkel said
that she would have liked to see tougher
measures come in beforehand
now with the current harsher lockdown in
place at the moment we see numbers still
high
although over christmas uh the reporting
of these numbers has been lagging so
numbers have been fluctuating
but experts had already warned that we
would see numbers staying high
over these few weeks and over christmas
there have been gathering small
gatherings of families getting together
so
we will have to see in the next few
weeks how this affects
the situation the numbers in the country
and see whether the current measures
are enough and julia what about the
situation
in german hospitals at the moment
the situation has been described as very
difficult
out of the over 26 000 intensive care
beds in the country
only around 4 000 are still free that
still gives
some leeway but if we look at the
different region the situ
the regions the situation is different
for example in
more affected regions like bavaria or
saxony a lot of hospitals are reaching
capacity
and doctors expects the the numbers of
patients there to remain
high over the next few weeks and julia
the the vaccination program here has
been criticized for being slow and
chaotic
is that because expectations were
unrealistic or did the robot just not
meet targets
according to the german health minister
jens spahn
what was promised has been delivered he
said that
the 1.3 million doses that had been
expected by the end of 2020
have been delivered by biontech pfizer
he said he expects another
4 million doses to be delivered by the
end of january
he also explained that the issue is not
that not enough doses were
ordered but that at the beginning of the
production
it is still slow and not as many doses
as needed can be produced
and he also said that as we saw in the
report
administering the vaccine in care homes
proceeds slower as
going ahead only with vaccination
centers so he has been defending his
government's actions
while criticism continues to mount dw's
julia saudelli with the latest
thank you
well let's talk about the impact of all
of this on business
in europe's largest economy we can speak
now to carson jeske the chief economist
at ing
germany carson thank you for joining us
we have some numbers
coming in today showing that retail
figures have actually been very strong
thanks to
online sales so what impact is this
prolonged winter lockdown
actually having on the german economy
it's still harder to come up with
numbers i think what we know is that
hotels restaurants travel culture so all
these factors that had already been hit
by the lockdown by the pandemic
throughout 2020
will also be hit the most visit this
time around
when you look at manufacturing sector
for example um
it has been done quite well in the
fourth quarter and also now at the start
of
of the new year here it will really
depend on whether schools will reopen or
not because we have i think something
like like 15
million parents of uh of of smaller
students
um so if they have to stay at home again
um this will have an impact on growth
so i think in some what you can tell
right now is that it's going to be a
very weak start
to the year 2021 probably another
contraction a mild contraction of the
economy
but i think with springtime with a
continuation of the rolling out of the
vaccine
we will also see then the german economy
recovering starting
second quarter if you look at a
comparison across europe
in the early stages of a pandemic the
german economy was doing
better than other european countries is
that still the case
um not really in all honesty when you
look at the
the lockdown matters we have seen since
november even with the tighter
restrictions before
christmas it is still somewhat lighter
than in
other countries compared with france for
example compared with what the uk
announced last night
so germany is still doing well um or
better
germany is also benefiting a lot from
this v-shaped recovery of the asian
economies led by china so the german
manufacturing sector
is clearly benefiting a lot but we also
know that this big
bang of physical stimulus which had been
announced throughout 2020
has not fully reached the economy yet
so if we would need to see more fiscal
stimulus
this year or at least paying out of the
already announced fiscal stimulus
to really get germany out of the
starting blocks faster than the rest
and carson you mentioned looking ahead
to the spring so how optimistic
are you that we will see a return
towards economic
normality in 2021
probably not normality but i think we
have to look through this high frequency
short-term noise of
where are there vaccinations where are
there no vaccinations
the lockdown will continue but i think
i'm very positive that with the second
quarter
we will see a reviving economy in europe
in the uk in the us and with a bit of
luck
and and really a good vaccination
strategy in the second half of
this year we could see for the first
time in a long while really a
synchronized
global recovery so yes as as dark as the
short-term outlook seems to be there is
clearly light at the end of the tunnel
okay that's some positive news there
krusten jeske chief economist at ing
germany thank you for joining us
british prime minister boris johnson has
announced a new nationwide lockdown
for england lasting until at least
mid-february to combat a fast-spreading
new coronavirus variant
it follows a warning from england's
chief medical officer
that without action the country's health
system could be overwhelmed
within the next three weeks
desperate times call for desperate
measures with boris johnson announcing
england would move into its third
national lockdown
similarly strict to the first one that
began last march
that means the government is once again
instructing you to stay at home
you may only leave home for limited
reasons permitted in law
such as to shop for essentials to work
if you
absolutely cannot work from home to
exercise
to seek medical assistance such as
getting a copied test
or to escape domestic abuse
with england experiencing a 50 jump in
the number of patients in hospital with
covert 19 since christmas day
scientists hospitals teachers unions
and opposition politicians have all
called for decisive action in recent
weeks
many parents will need support in the
coming days because the schools are shut
businesses will need support because
they won't be able to
operate that package needs to be put in
place as soon as possible because
compliance needs you know clear
messaging but also support for people to
make sure that they can
comply in wales where patients were
among the first to receive the uk's
second approved vaccine produced by
astrazeneca
tough lockdown measures have been in
place since the 20th
of december
hours before johnson's announcement
scotland's first
minister nicola sturgeon imposed similar
restrictions
while northern ireland's executive are
expected to follow suit
british hospitals now have more covert
19 patients than at the height of the
pandemic in spring
with resources low and staff overwhelmed
it's been one of the worst shifts of my
entire life
intense i'm looking after many more sick
patients than i
normally look after
[Music]
it's just overwhelming the whole
situation
and things aren't expected to improve
immediately
in spring it took nearly three weeks
after the introduction of the lockdown
for hospitalizations to reach their peak
let's look at some other developments in
the coronavirus pandemic now
indonesia will begin a nationwide
vaccination program on january 13th
president joko widodo will be given the
first shot of the vaccine made by a
chinese firm
brazil is reporting at least two cases
of the new more contagious coronavirus
variant
one of them after contact with travelers
from europe
mexico has granted approval to the
astrazeneca oxford vaccine that makes it
the second vaccine to get the go-ahead
there
meanwhile israel has approved the use of
the moderna covet-19
vaccine becoming the third country in
the world to do so after the u.s
and canada israel's vaccination program
has advanced more quickly than
anywhere else in the world well over a
million people have received the
bion tech shot around 15 percent of the
population
officials say they've secured six
million doses of the modern modern
vaccine and first deliveries are
expected very soon
and let's go to jerusalem now we can
speak to journalist sami soho sami good
to see you
what does this second vaccine mean for
israel as it pushes forward with its
rollout
yeah well indeed here in israel
because the campaign has been so
successful the israeli ministry of
health has announced today
that already one million three hundred
and seventy thousand israelis received
the
uh vaccine and um just yesterday
nearly 150 000 israelis received the
vaccine so because the campaign has been
so successful
there's already a high demand and
there's already
a clear concern that there will be a
shortage and therefore the
the deal that was struck with moderna is
important
though um it might take some time
they're talking about maybe another two
weeks we will get the first shipment
but there will be only a few tens of
thousands so i think that israel will
still be looking at pfizer
to get uh more supply you mentioned of
course the significance of this
sami just to jump in there you mentioned
that you know 15 million people
15 of the population around there has
been vaccinated to this point
why has that campaign been so successful
in israel
yeah well first of all the prime
minister
benjamin netanyahu who is facing a
elections on the 23rd of march has been
pushing and even his his greatest
critics here are giving
giving credit to the prime minister but
i would also say that
we have a good public health system here
in israel
and especially the hmos that are
established we have four hmos that are
spread out throughout the country
each and every community each and every
neighborhood has an hmo
and they've been working very hard to
give this vaccine
including on saturday here saturdays
usually nothing operates and they've
been giving vaccines
and this has been considered to be quite
a success
and the government is now talking about
issuing green passports
after those who will get the second
vaccine and with these green passports
they will be able to attend
a cultural event sports events and
they're talking about
opening up towards a passover the
upcoming
holiday in april journalist sami soho
speaking to us from
jerusalem thank you very much for that
update
now coronavirus restrictions have forced
people around the world to rediscover
home cooking people who once frequented
restaurants have become their own
caterers and as our next report from
india shows in some cases that's created
new business opportunities
gauri gupta has always found comfort in
baking
as an interior architect numbers and
science make sense to her
as does the precision of weighing
ingredients and baking times
she's glad she left her job as an
architect four years ago
to set up her at home bakery as simple
as pie
because it made 2020 per year defined by
the pandemic
a fantastic one for her i think because
of it being from home
because of it being produced by only one
person being touched by only one person
there's a certain level of trust that
clients have
with us i've actually managed to grow my
business
two-fold if not more customers love
what gauri calls her naughty and nice
bakes
alcohol-based cakes on the one hand and
foods that take dietary restrictions
into account on the
other her new clients are purely thanks
to her instagram page and word of mouth
gory acknowledges it hasn't been easy
from working 12 to 14 hour days to
scrambling to find yeast as supplies ran
out during india's lockdown
but she can't hire help in the kitchen
yet
because more hands on deck could mean
more exposure
if things get better in 2021 though she
hopes to expand her team of one
kusuma juneja and her daughter nicole
have had a fantastic 2022
they run a food delivery service called
mood in delhi
named after an ever-changing menu
inspired by whatever kusuma is in the
mood to cook
kusuma loves the kitchen and had always
wanted to do something with food
two years ago she launched mood on
instagram with nicole's help
cooking dishes from her childhood
influenced by cuisines from nepal
bhutan and tibet mood started as a once
a week service
after india's lockdown though spiking
demand has meant they now serve
five days of the week orders have
multiplied four or fivefold
nicole's job has been updating instagram
and chatting with customers
she loves sharing the rave reviews they
receive with kusuma nicole says mood has
been therapeutic
making the months fly by in a year where
she hasn't left home since
early march it was just a huge blessing
i would say because you know we we found
something we were able to do something
that kept us busy that you know made
sure that we were productive so you
didn't really miss the
outside world and i think some days in
that kitchen you almost even forget that
everything that is happening is
happening you know it's just we're just
like we're in a little
bubble filled with momos nicole and
kusuma say they found their sweet spot
in 2020
and aren't really looking to expand
their fresh food output
nicole does have some ideas though
frozen foods is one
and they're popular meat pickles another
last year was overwhelmingly eventful
for the doe
and it will set the tone for 2021 one of
gratitude
and an enduring love for good food